Caesarean section is commonly referred to as the c section and
is a surgical procedure to open the mother's abdomen and uterus during childbirth
.
Some caesarean section is planned.
If it is determined that
this procedure is required
, the key points requiring a Caesarean section include abnormal prepartum zone plate
fetal distress, etc.
The second head cannot pass through the birth canal or the body position is perpendicular to the approach.
Abnormal delivery or long-term labor pains may occur if all are first. Caesarean
section
has a low caesarean section and partially
or totally blocks cesarean section.  It happens when
the life of the fetus is urgently endangered due to lack of blood flow through the placenta or
navel.
Other situations that may require a caesarean section include:
Childbirth Large intrauterine genital herpes
or other while athletes or under-managed diabetes  And medical disorders such as high blood pressure
. Your doctor will also use an ultrasound to monitor the fetal heart
and decide if you should give birth to your fetus by caesarean section
.
If you haven't inserted a caesarean section, start it and insert a catheter into the assault to drain urine
Enter the operating room and anesthetize.
General anesthesia may also be used
.
Called a cut,
the doctor then puts a second
scalpel into the caesarean section.
It usually takes about 5 minutes from to delivery.The
doctor in charge then fixes the navel brain with fasteners, removes the plate you want to cut,
and sew the earth and abdomen firmly.It
usually takes about 45 minutes.
Usually after caesarean section.
I will be hospitalized on the 23rd. During the hospitalization, I will be able to breastfeed and take a rest while the newborn is sleeping.
Most patients can take care of their newborn shortly after delivery,
but
it can take 6 to 8 weeks to fully heal. Scars fade as they heal.